l'étranger
n'a d'avenir pour personne
nous sommes seuls dans ce pays
je n'ai pas vraiment d'endroit spécifique mais
je veux un meilleur endroit un pâturage plus vert
vous voyez le Royaume-Uni est un lieu d'opportunités
sur
votre force vient
le  l'argent pour faire le visa c'est à
nouveau le problème, donc les gens vous diront
avec votre forfait familial est de 12 millions d'
argent
tout plan que vous avez en tête ce n'est pas
ce que vous venez de divulguer au monde,
vous commencez à vous préparer
jusqu'à ce que la chose clique
avant vous  appelez les gens et dites-leur
celui-ci
fatigué
ce que Speedy Ransom
ne commence pas
nous jackpot de ce pays
il y a un cross-board un échec d'
opportunité il y a un un
chômage cross-board
il y a une politique de terrain cross-board
il y a une croix  -embarquer dans un système éducatif sur le terrain,
euh bien sûr, ce qu'il fait, cela crée un
sentiment de fuite
comme décent toute idée que nous réaliserons
pour la bourse comme celle-ci
ouais
ce qui est tragique dans tout cela, c'est
qu'au-delà juste le le le le
très  difficile, vous savez, les résultats de tous
ces risques sont le fait que le Nigeria en tant que
pays a besoin de ses ressources humaines c'est la
plus grande ressource du Nigeria ce
n'est pas le pétrole c'est la ressource humaine
avant
minasan konichiwa ou Ohio
j'ai senti que je pouvais le faire au Nigeria d'ici là
je me sentais  Je ne peux pas, alors la meilleure chose à faire
est de se battre contre Jack, quittez simplement le pays
mon travail, vous savez, une sorte d'emplois à temps partiel
j'ai fait des emplois à temps partiel dans une
entreprise de déménagement, beaucoup de gens la mentalité
ici
est que quand vous  voyager à l'étranger quand vous
conduisez à côté de vous voyagez à l'étranger à tout ce qui est
rose non non avec l'expérience que
j'ai au Japon me fait comprendre
que chaque vie est difficile
restons en arrière et luttons là-dessus
c'est la même chose que nous devons faire ici
nous sommes tellement bénis
tout ce que nous recherchons il y a au
coin de la rue ici est avec nous
ici